- [Emma] Here's a bird's eye view
of the monumental shifts happening
across the American workforce right now.
The lines above zero show the sectors
that saw the strongest job growth,
since right before the pandemic.
While the lines below show the ones
that have seen the biggest declines.
It's evidence of a larger phenomenon
that is touching almost every industry.
- Business is closing their doors,
employees working crazy hours.
It's all because of the
so-called Great Resignation.
- [Emma] In August,
more than 4 million
workers quit their jobs,
a record 20-year high.
- A lot of people are
taking time to reevaluate
what they want to do with their lives
and what work actually means to them.
- [Emma] For millions of
workers and businesses,
the Great Resignation is a period
that could define the
future of American labor.
This is how we got to this point
and what we know about
where the workers are going.
The first thing to know is that this chart
is showing just a slice of the labor force
between February, 2020
and September, 2021,
from the Labor Department's
September jobs report.
There are hundreds of other industries
that have seen growth and declines
during this period as well.
Some that didn't have data
available for September.
But what the numbers suggest is clear,
thousands of workers lost
their jobs in certain sectors,
and many aren't returning.
Let's go back to spring 2020
when the pandemic took hold.
- Weekly unemployment claims
had a stunning new high today
with 6.6 million Americans
filing just last week.
- [Emma] As the pandemic spread,
businesses shuttered their
doors and tens of millions
of people lost their jobs.
To help workers and
businesses stay afloat,
the federal government began
handing out relief payments.
And if we look widely at the labor data,
it's clear that certain
industries lost more workers
and had a harder time gaining
them back than others.
Employment in motion picture
and sound recording
industries is still 23% lower
than it was in February, 2020.
And other sectors hit hardest
by the pandemic have been
travel and hospitality.
It's clear if you look at this line,
employment and travel arrangement
and reservation services
is still almost 25% below
February, 2020 levels.
The biggest decline among job
sectors in September data.
- The weaker job growth
in travel related sectors
is probably a reflection
of both companies
inability to find workers
but also weaker demand for
travel related services,
especially as the pandemic
continued during the summer.
- [Emma] Sarah Chaney
Cambon has been reporting
on the Great Resignation
and American labor shortage
for the Wall Street Journal.
She pointed out that transit
and ground passenger transportation jobs
also saw a huge hit, losing over 18%.
One part of this sector
that has been impacted
heavily is ride sharing,
which has experienced a
nationwide shortage of drivers.
And while some have slowly returned
as government relief has ended,
many of these workers are
staying off the roads.
For workers with demanding,
lower paying jobs,
the pandemic relief payments
may have made them less
motivated to return.
And another concern weighing heavily
on many has been the
risk of getting COVID.
Between mid June and early October,
the number of people who
said they couldn't work
because they were sick
with or caring for someone
with COVID rose by 2 million.
Also during this time,
some older workers chose to
reassess their priorities.
The Federal Reserve
Bank of Dallas estimates
that 2 1/2 million people
retired during the pandemic,
about twice as many as in 2019.
And that approximately 1.5
million of these workers
would not have retired if the
pandemic had not happened.
- So a lot of baby
boomers have retired early
during the pandemic in part
because of concerns about COVID.
Others have seen, really, big
gains from the stock market
or housing prices going up a ton
and so they're in a comfortable
financial situation.
- [Emma] But many of the workers
who are leaving jobs aren't
leaving the workforce entirely.
- A lot of people are quitting their jobs,
maybe because they've experienced burnout
during the pandemic,
or they're just looking
for different opportunities.
- [Emma] And an increasing number
of these workers are switching jobs.
- If you're seeing workers
switch from one industry
to another it's oftentimes
because they can get better pay
or better working
conditions in the industry
that they're transitioning to.
- [Emma] Some employers
are offering higher wages
and healthcare benefits to
try and attract new workers.
And the US economy added
about 3 million jobs
from April through September this year.
Though, employment was
still down over 3% compared
with the month before the pandemic hit.
Still, many of these workers
have started jobs in industries
that have benefited from
pandemic driven shifts.
- E-commerce is really taken off
and that's created a lot
of jobs at warehouses,
at manufacturers and shipping
and postal companies.
And we see that very
clearly in the job data.
- [Emma] Couriers and messenger jobs saw
more than an 18% increase,
the largest of any sector
in the September data.
While the warehousing
and storage field saw
over an 11% rise.
- Some industries were doing really well
before the pandemic started
and the pandemic only helps them,
anything related to science and research
and development was
growing pretty strongly
before the pandemic started
and then, after you
had demand for vaccines
and so that definitely
creates a lot of jobs.
- [Emma] You can see it here.
Scientific research and
development service jobs grew
by almost 10%.
COVID cases have declined since
the September jobs report.
And some economists are optimistic
that more workers will return this fall.
Still, others are concerned
that labor shortages reflect
longer-term shifts away
from the workforce that won't reverse.
Meaning, some of these
industries could be faced
with long lasting changes.